Can Fish Count?
Numberphile
Films by Brady Haran
Brian Butterworth: It turns out
and there's now quite a history of this.
Relatively recently people have found that
there are a lot of species who can do
number tasks.
By number tasks I mean
tasks which depend upon
understanding
the number of objects in the display,
or what we would call "numerosity".
So, you have to be very careful here,
because you can't talk to other species,
and they can't talk to you.
So you can't explain to them
what aspects of the stimulus
you want them to respond to.
But you have to design the stimuli
rather carefully,
so that the critical aspect of the stimuli
is the numerosity of objects.
Actually, before the second world war,
a brilliant German ethologist called Otto Koehler,
had shown that corvids, crows,
jackdaws and so on,
had quite a good number sense,
that they could match to a sample
numbers up to about 7.
So he showed them a sample,
black blobs,
then they had to select
one of the two or three objects
which had the same number
of blobs.
The blobs would be arranged differently
If they got it right they got rewarded,
if they got it wrong they didn't.
And they were pretty good at this,
these corvids.
Since then, there was a...
Since the 30's there's been
a kind of a hiatus in research of
animal numerical cognition.
But since the 90's it really started
to take off again.
And we now know that a whole range
of different animals
can do this.
In the wild and in laboratories,
particularly in laboratories.
We were interested in the counting
abilities of fish.
Now, small fish often swim
in shoals,
and if they are in a shoal
there's a smaller risk of predation
than if they are by themselves.
And if they are in a bigger shoal,
they have a smaller risk of predation
than if they are in a smaller shoal.
Brady Haran: Safety in numbers.
Brian Butterworth: Safety in numbers, exactly.
So you can use this natural behavior
of the small fish,
and test it the laboratory.
So you can put them in
a transparent tank,
with a few fish on this side
and a few more fish on the other side,
and you see which side
they swim to.
It's been checked, not by me,
but by my collaborators,
that they will swim to the shoal
of the side of the tank with more fish in it.
What we were interested to do
in a paper we published this year
was to see whether they had
a difference between small number perception
and large number perception.
So in humans, what happens is
that if you have to compare
4 versus 3,
4 versus 2,
4 versus 1,
3 versus 2,
this is all equally easy.
I doesn't depend on the ratio
of one number to the other.
So 4 against 1 is just as easy
as 4 against 3.
However, once you get larger numbers
let's say, 8 against 7,
or 8 against 5,
then there's a ratio effect.
That is, the bigger the difference
between those two numbers
the easier it is.
The question is, would this be true
of guppies,
which are small fish about that big,
relatively small brain.
And the answer was - Yes,
that these small fish didn't show
a ratio effect
when you asked them to compare
4 versus 1 as compared to 4 versus 3.
But for larger numbers, they did show
a ratio effect,
which suggests that like us
they have these two systems,
small number system and
a larger number system.
And we thought this was really quite
an intriguing result.
Brady Haran: I can imagine someone
at home thinking:
"Well, surely the fish just looks
at two different groups of fish
or shoals of fish,
and can just measure which one is bigger,
which one takes up more volume
and swims towards that.
And it hasn't used any number sense there,
it just used an understanding of
how big something is."
How is the experiments that you have been
involved with getting around that?
Brian Butterworth: Well, it is very difficult to control,
because not only there are more fish over here
that go swimming around,
and you can have fewer fish over there,
and they are swimming around.
So, it's really quite difficult for the subject fish
to be able to make an estimate,
even though they do it actually rather well.
How do we know that they are
enumerating the fish,
that side versus that side,
Well, there are ways in which
you can manipulate
the amount of fishiness on this side
and the amount of fishiness on that side.
For example by putting slightly larger fish
on this side
to balance the number of fish on that side.
That creates some problems,
because of fish psychology
which I'm not an expert in.
Like, some fish prefer to swim in shoals
with larger fish
and so, you know, that creates complications.
However, my collaborators have done
a nice training experiment,
in which the fish doesn't have to choose
between two shoals,
it has to select a gate into another
tank, to join its friends.
And above the gate will be
a number of blobs.
And the fish has to choose
the right number of blobs.
It would have had a training session
in which
a certain number of blobs will be rewarded
and a different number of blobs will not.
Let's say, 3 is rewarded,
2 is not rewarded.
In the test there will be different blobs.
There will be 3-ness and 2-ness,
but different arrangements of 3-ness and 2-tess.
And the fish can learn this.
Actually it can learn it quite well.
So, there's now quite good evidence that
the fish can respond to number.
But, of course, they might also in the wild
be responding to other cues
like the amount of fishiness in
the neighborhood,
and, of course, these are typically
correlated with a number.
So, you want to try
and tease them apart experimentally
but in real life, of course, they tend
to get together.
Brady Haran: How is understanding
the mathematical cognition
or the number cognition of guppies help anything?
Why do you have
an interest in this?
Brian Butterworth: Well, we want to know
what kinds of capacities
the human brain inherits.